ces bouges tous valides les deux autres
claire est adhérente depuis un an une
épicerie bio 100 salariés
les pizzas ou thouars à guyancourt au
départ je suis venu pour trouver ce que
je cherchais fur et à mesure on peut
être force de proposition dès qu'on
connaît à un petit producteur en parler
et il en fait le proposer monté par des
membres de la sauce régal il ya trois
ans l'épicerie fonctionne depuis deux
ans à l'ouverture de l'épicerie une
vingtaine d'adhérents et participer
aujourd'hui ils sont 65
le principe c'est que chacun des deux
heures de son temps par mois donc au
final ça peut paraître beaucoup mais en
fait ce qu'on réfléchisse et en fait on
au lieu de regarder un film qui dure
deux heures dont on vient une fois par
mois participer à au façonnement
l'épicerie un lieu unique où aujourd'hui
sont vendus les produits de 30
producteurs venus de toute la france
comme les terres du lendemain maraîcher
de molière on essaye de distribuer le
maximum en local pour pour revaloriser
les producteurs locaux et les produits
locaux parce que nous du coup on produit
des légumes et des plantes aromatiques
en permaculture on aimerait que que ça
puisse toucher un roman le le public
local quoi en premier lieu pour les
prochains mois les pidio outre aux arts
vise la centaine d'adhérents prochain
projet un café participatif